I don't know anyone here watches that
HBO show the jinks big hit that shot
yeah it's fascinating it's about that
creepy millionaire accused of three
different murders have you seen this
thing in yeah yeah Robert Durst is his
name he's a scary guy yeah very scary
well at least he was arrested last week
so we don't have to worry about him
anymore they arrested him well I mean
you say that but he's really sneaky and
he's rich he's got connections I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if he's always
already managed to get out of prison and
gone on the lam now you really think so
oh yeah with this kind of money he could
be anywhere by now
anywhere that was him did you see that
yeah that was all that was Robert doors
Oh daddy
my god it's terrible I just praise God
and let's just pray that we never see
that clammy sweaty weirdo ever again
because I find mantis
[Applause]
oh I hate that guy so my arrabal yeah
all fall he's creepy
[Applause]
I want to help you it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
call security
Jeff where are you
Oh
[Applause]
it's over my god chef what the hell was
that
yeah
got his line right hey and just really
sorry everyone let's just put that
behind us we have a great show tonight a
fantastic show those glasses are so out
of date from the new movies the
divergent series in surgeon and flower
[Applause]
that series FXX series the league in the
county seven series Kroll show Nick
Kroll is
people guest Tweety
[Applause]
you